alright we are live on another google+
hangout today I'm really excited to have
Dolores Clark with me Dolores is from
the UK her website is sorted for you
coat UK and it's in the description
below and she reached out to me and
wanted to ask me about how I managed my
time and my motivations and I said hey
why don't we just do a google hangout
and you can ask me whatever questions
you have and also put it live on YouTube
for everybody else to share in as well
so Deloris welcome and over to you I am
so grateful thank you so much for
agreeing to speak with me I've been
following you for about maybe a year now
and I'll just give a bit of background
just for my listeners who going to
listen this is my very first visual
public google hangout all of the recipe
or my interviews have been previously on
podcasts and those visuals so thank you
for that and I can't believe it's just
such a big one for me and for the people
in the UK who have not heard of Evan
Carmichael shame on you I'm they're
going to explain um who evan is he is an
entrepreneur and started at a real early
age and we'll talk about that in a bit
and Evan motivates entrepreneurs so
that's what drew me to him I don't
usually reach out to occasionally our
old respond to our newsletters of things
but I don't usually but it's the
sincerity that that them Evan conveyed
that actually made me reach out this
time I don't know what you do you every
time I see you on your video your
YouTube channel I'm it is what to do
that to me there was a lady who was um
to a cyber bullied I think you know i
watched you on them youtube and you're
discussing that I think you've gone to
Malaysia you'd reached out to this lady
and then people wouldn't wouldn't
interact with her friends of hand
whenever so you had a whole whole group
of people interacting they're lining up
and having photos taken with that I
thought that's lovely and also the way
that you love your wife and the gifts
that you give her online
I think this guy sincere unless because
usually you can't tell you can't turn
but with you I thought this guy's for
real so I'd like to speak with him and
that came across because you want to
help other people so um yeah so I'd like
to know from how have you always been
relentlessly excited and motivational
and upbeat what were you like as a child
oh wow we go right into the deep
questions eh well first off thank you
for that warm introduction opening
that's very humbling um was like as a
child I was a bit of a chump to make
sure I think as a child um I remember
growing up I didn't I wasn't always
great at following the rules on which i
think is probably a good thing as an
entrepreneur both both myself I have two
sisters one older and one younger I'm in
the middle and none of us ended up in
traditional jobs we're all doing our own
thing and I think my parents really
encouraged us to follow our own passions
and our own dreams and even though both
my parents have very traditional
corporate lives and jobs and that's how
they grew up all three of us kids went
off to do her own thing and so when I
was younger I I didn't do well in school
I remember are used to always between me
my sisters I was always the worst one I
used to whenever report card time came I
always have to sit down with my parents
and I knew yeah yeah yeah like sit in
their room and talk about my grades and
I wasn't a failing student but uh you
know I might have had b's and c's and
and you know my family they had higher
expectations for me but it was always
there was always left as a positive my
mother's last name is Chris truly and my
father's last name is Carmichael and
they would always tell me you're
Casterly Carmichael you can do this
there wasn't me they always made me feel
like I could believe in myself and it
was like that all the way up until high
school and then my last year of high
school I don't know what changed but my
own expectations
myself became higher than what my
parents expectations were of me and I
had you know straight 90s in my final
year of school and I don't know why I
applied myself more just I i upped the
ante you know and i made it more i had
higher expectations of myself and ever
since then I've been applying myself to
what I find interesting and I'm
passionate about and even if it doesn't
always make sense logically getting into
it but so far it's worked out yeah yeah
you started real early age as an
entrepreneur and did you have an idea
then what you wanted to do so you went
into software denier because well I'm
going to get you you I was this I listen
to your story a lot and you said there
was bitsy times you wanted to give up
and I was thinking not i want to wish
ill for anybody but i like to hear how
people overcame their challenges and i
remember the stories about when you were
just living on baked beans or something
and i was thinking i want you to tell
other entrepreneurs who are struggling
and thinking that they're that close to
giving up why you didn't give up and
what what could you through yeah that's
a awesome question i guess there's a
couple questions in there I think I've
always had entrepreneurial tendencies I
just didn't i didn't know because it was
an entrepreneurship wasn't in my family
you know my parents weren't
entrepreneurs I didn't grow up with
entrepreneurs in my life and so my first
venture was on I was five years old I
took my three-year-old little sister and
we drew you know pic pictures like kids
do and then we went door-to-door selling
our art and I sold you know an art piece
to my next door neighbor for ten cents
or something that was the first deal I
ever made as an entrepreneur you know
growing up I had lots of different micro
businesses and I was obsessed with
baseball cards for a while in the 90s
and made you know made some money doing
that but but still in high school you
know and you're finally your high school
they ask you to write where do you see
yourself in 20 years
in my yearbook i wrote i saw myself as a
VP at a bank so all I went through the
system and even though I had all these
internal tendencies there was nothing in
my environment to spark that you know I
didn't have I didn't have a role model I
didn't have a course that I took so I
thought I'd I thought it'd be happy in
the world of banking I'm so glad as it
was the vein cane so changing University
and when's my first University and I
thought I was going to be an investment
banker and uh I connected with two
entrepreneurs who are on University who
had a company that was doing okay we're
not doing really well um you know they
had a software product that they were
trying to get launched and they had a
few customers but they wanted to turn it
into it the full time thing and I said
you want to come on and help me help us
build this they were two researchers
scientists and not necessarily in the
marketing side so I came on to try to
help them with the business in the
marketing and I started to love it right
this is cool i have my own opportunity
to do whatever I want to do and follow
my ideas and it was so much more
enjoyable than the courses i was taking
at University at the time and then the
moment a big deciding moment came where
I got offers to work with McKinsey
Consulting and merrill lynch and out of
the pod company what's that and big
companies big company if you're looking
at strategic consulting McKinsey that's
it that's the company to go to and and
merrill lynch and investment banking is
one of the hero companies that i looked
up to you know if I saw that in my last
year of high school said I would have
opportunity with merrill lynch and
mckenzie lee of course right that's
awesome and and they flew me around the
i remember flying out to New York and
they put me up in the Waldorf Astoria
which is a really well known and pricey
hotel and you know they're putting the
full sales blitz on you um and I don't
know what I don't know what it was you
know I
I I what at a curiosity to learn and
then at the same time I'm making you
know I'm my business I'm making three
hundred dollars a month Fred like
nothing I'm not surviving i'm eating the
bean i was eating beans for lunch every
day because it was cheap and it was
filling um it was usually cane beans
because i don't know how to make baked
beans would open up a can prolly cuz she
got your protein you get everything then
that was it that was what made me get
through um and then here are these
companies who are throwing eighty to a
hundred thousand dollars starting salary
wow that mean and i honestly didn't know
what to do and the logical the logical
framework is hey you know you can't make
this business happen it hasn't happened
yet you've been trying for number of
months it hasn't taken off this isn't
going to work out go do the job that you
always want it and what helped me was i
remember hearing some stores from famous
entrepreneurs like Michael Dell and Jeff
Bezos and thinking about how they got
started and I didn't want to live in
with regret I a lot of my friends were
taking a year off you know after you
graduate university take a year off you
go do whatever you want then then you go
and chase your life and they were going
traveling or whatever and I said you
know what I'm gonna I'm gonna try this
for a year I'm gonna give myself a year
see if I can make it work just to give
it a shot to know that it'll work or it
won't work because I don't want to be 70
looking back in my life and really
wishing ah you know there was something
there and I really wish I gave myself
that shot and that's what gave me the
courage to go forward I felt honestly
like you know what this job opportunity
is amazing but I could probably still
get that next year my business really
dying here so I'm gonna I'm just gonna
give myself a year and that gave me the
courage to kind of keep going uh it was
a it was a rough year though that was
that was brutal um and as you said I
almost quit and I was making as I said
nothing 300 bucks a mile
not able to survive and up until that
point everything I had applied myself to
I had success right I have high
standards for myself I had you know
straight 90s in my last year in high
school and university when I knew that
if I put my passion and effort into
something i would get results the more I
worked on something tomorrow would get
results and here I was poured everything
I had into this business and I wasn't
getting results not getting any more
money not getting any more customers and
it just it it takes a toll you know on
your self-worth exactly yeah and I'm
starting to feel like man I feel like
garbage right now you know I feel like
I'm not contributing anything and and
and I just felt it was the lowest of the
low and I remember one day it was a
family function and my business partner
calls me up and and we're just we're
just disagreeing now right like you have
different visions now where the
company's going to go you're you're
struggling trying to figure out a way to
make it work and I just told them I quit
like I can't do this anymore I have you
know no self-esteem anymore working
working with you at this business it's
not you it's not personal just I need to
do something where I can feel valuable
again and I quit and and and we hung up
the phone and and I just started crying
crying toll ibly to hear myself say that
I quit on something that I was you know
passionate about and tears were coming
out of my eyes my nose just this is like
the worst one of the worst moments in my
entire life and I remember my mom came
up and she put her hand on my shoulder
you know she heard me crying from
downstairs and I didn't remember what
she said you know she tried to soothe me
somehow i totally don't remember what
she said and um you know I want the bed
slept a little and and then the next day
I just woke up and felt like I can't
quit like I think so much into this I've
gotta find I've just got to find another
way to stain I've got to find another
way to do it and and I showed up for
work you know at my
we worked out on my business partners
apartment ah colleagues say what you
doing here I and luckily he didn't give
me a hard time right he didn't he to his
credit he didn't say why are you here
you quit on me and have a money go he
just opened the door and went to work
again and and I'm so I'm very thankful
and grateful for that but I had to find
a different way to stand because what we
were doing wasn't working and yeah the
light bulb for me went off and I
realized hey I'm not the first guy to
try to sell software before melds other
people who have done this I don't need
to come up with every new idea myself
and I looked at Bill Gates who is in
software and it was in different kind of
software but still software and looked
at how did he get started and not how he
makes an extra million dollars now we're
next to billion dollars now you know how
did he go from zero to one that's what I
wanted to do 0 to 1 yeah and it was all
through partnerships and so I applied
that strategy to my business and started
looking for partners and distributors
and people who can ally with in within a
couple weeks I landed my first deal with
a company out of the UK for 13 and a
half thousand dollars and and that you
know I doesn't seem like a lot of money
but for me mmm making 300 bucks a month
13 and a half K that was you can look
from the bike beans that was that was
celebration time you know and uh we
celebrated with McDonald's french fries
right that this is how like nothing we
had we would go to McDonald's and
celebrate with fries whenever yeah so we
could go and get like a full meal now at
McDonald's here um but more importantly
I had a model that I could replicate
right that was only one deal now I could
do that again and again and again and
again and then we started to quickly
seeing growth and we had more customers
and we'd landed deals with NASA and
johnson Johnson and within a couple
years we we were acquired and we went
from nothing to massive success in a
short amount of time
because i was able to model what worked
for Bill Gates uh but it wasn't it
wasn't easy right like I almost quit we
struggled a lot i had no money at the
start you know i had to tell my friends
my friends would have to take those big
jobs with the big money and and I I had
to say no that I couldn't go out for
drinks with them or celebrate birthday
parties with them yeah I told them I was
too busy yeah I couldn't afford it I
couldn't afford twenty dollars to go
have a beer and you know a sandwich or
something I know it's too embarrassed
you know I was supposed to be living the
entrepreneur life you know I'm the one
to turn down the jobs to do my own thing
and here i am not able to survive so
it's definitely some tough tough early
years to get it going yeah that leads me
on to oh there's so many questions not
enough time um now yes could be hot on
to what you're doing now and and and
you're actually motivating entrepreneurs
you want to reach out to a billion
entrepreneurs why why it's a great
question i don't know i love
entrepreneurs there's just something
about entrepreneurs that i love people
who are trying to make a difference
people who are trying to follow their
their passion and follow their dreams I
just it resonates with me um and I
remember I walk into I first started
helping entrepreneurs because I sold my
business and had some success and had a
lot of attention and I got asked to do a
speaking event with the ymca doesn't
know if this why I'm see in the UK is
Wednesday yes so um you know there are
community groups and said hey can you
come speak to our groups of
entrepreneurs and I said sure happy to
share what worked for me and they
promoted it for a couple weeks and the
people I knew I promoted to and said hey
come to this for your van at the YMCA
and I spent so much time marketing it
and invested into my slides and is going
to be perfect presentation and I get to
the you know this is a day of my palms
are sweaty and my heart's beating I'm
nervous is my first presentation yes big
room all set up and three people showed
up Oh
in my heart like sunk yeah I spent all
this time marketing and they marketed it
and it's a free event and three people
showed up and after I got passed up you
know initial disappointment I said well
I did this work so let's turn it into
the best thing for these three people
that it can be and it was awesome you
know those three people came out as
changed people and I knew that I had an
impact on their lives and and I walked
away from that session thinking I don't
know how I'm ever gonna make money doing
this but I have to asa like it Buell's
me so much and so since then I've
continued to expand in test and I feel
that stuff and I've had success with
other things but it's all been around
helping entrepreneurs I don't know it's
like it's an irrational it's an
irrational self-loathing that's a golden
ollie it's a calling it's irrational i
have no logical explanation for it I
could talk to entrepreneurs all day long
they give me energy they don't take it
and it's just something that that I love
um so you have three people there and
you thought I know this is what I want
to do and you have got thousands of
people on your mailing list that you
reach out to hat that's something that I
struggle with sir I'm slighting you to
the whole twitter facebook um linkedin
things and getting it right how do you
go from zero so what you have now ah
yeah it's a great question i think first
of all you had to figure out what style
is best for you um my favorite social
media channel is YouTube I love you too
I'm a very visual learner and so I like
being able to see a video you know um
you know if you ask me for an interview
I'd much rather do it on video then have
me right out answers to questions right
my style some people love writing and
that's awesome and some people love
talking and so a podcast might be a
better fit me I love the visual aspect
that's what I went on YouTube and I
think you've got to find what you love
and then find the social media network
that fits you best and then just start
sharing really valuable stuff you know
my first youtube videos uh we're not
fantastic you know okay look at that Lee
well in fact it's pretty embarrassing
people look at them though they still
watch them and I still get thumbs up and
still get comments and I'm thinking man
I please come and watch the new stuff
because it's so much better than that
first you know serious plus sine a' or
twice a day with your own post song in
yeah i have two videos every day coming
out on youtube and and it's uh because i
love it and i've invested like I go all
in on something that I'm excited and
passionate about that's how you get
better that's how you find your joy
that's how you will find new things to
talk about and make successful if you
don't have time to make one video a
month for your YouTube channel you're
not going to get great results on
YouTube it's not going to happen um I'm
part of an agency so I have a have an
agent who represents me who hooks me
into speaking gigs and book deals and TV
shows that kind of stuff and when we
first started together he said you don't
have a lot of experience on on YouTube
and on TV and I don't know if I can work
with you get you to rob you have a great
message but your skills aren't there yet
and so I was borderline like I almost
didn't get in so I was like worst at the
agency uh-huh within a state with a
couple months I became the best practice
on what to do on my youtube channel and
their media trainers are now using my
channel as as the one to look to like
look what Evans doing here's where you
can do for your channel 2 and that's
only because I worked hard at it and
took their advice a lot of the people at
the agency me may have a hard time
finding time to do one video a week I'm
cranking out to a day so I'm getting
better really fast cuz I'm putting the
effort and love into it and so if
anybody it's not like I have a natural
gift right then you go back on my
channel and you will notice i do not
have her that
get for this hard work and passion
getting started I would start with pick
the pick the social network that you
feel best fits your personality and then
and then commit yourself to it just like
anything else you will get better as you
get in there try it I always think about
adding value to your community right so
all the videos that I have the social
media posts that I have they're not
sales pitches so I'll come by my stuff
come check out my website it's trying to
add value and help help the community
out um so the basically is specializing
in what you feel most comfortable with
um what you've also mentioned is the
importance of having that support
because where I am we've got something
called the e hub Enterprise hub mess for
startup companies and I find that so
useful because it's giving you things
that you would have thought of if you're
on your own I'm so like legal
information and marketing things so who
do you have do you have a mastermind
group that you still in touch with or do
you have your team pretty box ideas or
where'd you get fresh ideas where do you
get motivation when you're feeling down
that's a fantastic question um yeah
you're pumping out the questions today
it's good i like it you know what I
could talk to you for like two days
straight to be honest most of the ideas
and motivation and inspiration i get is
by looking at other famous entrepreneurs
uh that's part of why i created a new
series on my channel that every morning
at 7am my time I launch new video with
the famous entrepreneur and their
message so it's it's Howard chills from
starbucks or Warren Buffett or Steve
Jobs or Bill Gates or arnold
schwarzenegger jim carrion and their
their messages and i find inspiration in
the big things that they are doing um i
have great role models around me to help
me with my uh being a good human being
you know i think my parents really
helped me instill that
sense of value and trust and and how to
treat other people but in terms of where
do I get ideas and inspiration
motivation it's coming from people
who've done a lot more than me I have a
mastermind group that I've set up and
formed and in it helps it helps it's
nice to bounce some ideas off of people
but I think most of my inspiration will
come from those famous entrepreneurs
people who are doing big things you know
that I think a lot of entrepreneurs
you're going to be a product of your
environment you know whatever
environment you're in your routines your
habits your beliefs that's that's that
holds you where you are it holds you
where you are prevents you from doing
something bigger it'll keep you from
going down but it also holds you where
you are and so if you want to change if
you want to accomplish something bigger
you have to really change your
environment change your beliefs you
change your surroundings you change
what's in your office to change
potential your friends you change the
media you consume in the books you read
that has to change if you want to go and
do bigger things so I try to surround
myself if you want to be great you have
to surround yourself with greatness so
that's what I try to do and that's not
the discredit my mastermind group i
guess but thinking about people who've
done like just way way way way more even
if I've never met them my favorite
entrepreneur is AP Giannini who's the
founder of bank of america and and most
people don't know his story and most
people think a banker really a banker is
your favorite entrepreneur but but the
man it was amazing he believed in the
little guy he funded entrepreneurs like
Walt Disney when nobody would believe in
a guy like Walt Disney he gave loans to
people based on a handshake and a look
in their eye can you imagine the banker
giving you a loan based on a handshake
and I look in your eye it's that good
intuition thing yeah and he loved the
little guy like that's why he started
and that's love I love the little guy to
love the entrepreneur love seeing them
go um and so try to surround yourself
with greatness try to surround yourself
with people who have done what you're
trying to do and that in love are you I
get useless
so Anthony well I appreciate that and
the news August part of it right i mean
yeah for me at least I think you need
something daily every day you need
something because even if it's a quick
hit because uh you could be on fire one
day right like you watch you watch me as
broadcast and listen to your podcast ah
that's amazing Dolores like delivered
their amazing rock and then the next day
you wake up and you're starting over
again yeah all that energy you had is
gone and so you need to have a morning
routine that sets you up for greatness
every single day I'm whether that's a
newsletter whether it's videos whether
it's you know quotes stories I used to
read there's a book called radicals and
visionaries which I still have here
which is quick hits of famous
entrepreneur stories like three pages I
used to read one of those every morning
just just too ah you know get me excited
get me Thea and beyond my comfort zone
yeah yeah because I like the story of
Colonel Saunders and their Kentucky
bright care see ya padri thousand a
thousand knows before he got his first
Jess yeah and he was like in his 60s or
something before he even started so many
entrepreneurs to think on to all the
start of business I'm 45 I'm too old to
start Colonel Sanders was in his 60s way
from taking my McDonald's was in his 50s
before you started so it's never too
late i speared it's just is that
limiting belief people have yeah it
depends what you want and what you what
you dare to believe I guess I can't let
you go without talking about your Zuger
is you i love it because um you
recommend it to music and number 103
because i can't remember how many you
have there's lots of them yeah ah
collector ii was launching your business
and that was about setting intentions
and and your motivations for doing what
you do fantastic and something else that
made me cry you know you had to put them
while you're doing something I've ever
and stop it this is another thing that
you really have to be introspective look
up what's deep down that's what keeps
you going as well because every so often
you read it again you think ah that's
what's keeping me going but what I like
about it is that you've got 14
no matter where you are in your business
so I think okay got 10 3 i'm going to
have to go back because i got the series
and look at the initial ones as well
because that's going to be useful i
think so wherever you are in your
business it just helps you to go that
bit further I think so thank you for
that yeah i launched those because uh
you know I make the YouTube videos and
and it's hard to go super in-depth you
know i'm making a five minute video or
even a seven-minute video ah and people
want more and i don't have the time to
jump into everybody's business in New
keely um and so I made the zucca guides
as a it's it's my thoughts and a
worksheet that it's basically what i
would go through with you if you invited
me over to your house and we would sit
down for two hours and talk about how to
start a business these are all the
things that i would have you do and so I
find that giving it to people in a
package is a little more in depth than
just watching a five minute video um the
laws we've got a bunch of people
watching and asking questions do you
want to take a few of those two hotels
answer ownza they're chomping at the bit
so some of them socially the first one
is Jolin are six question compared to
when you started and now how easy is it
for you to make videos so I mean you can
answer that from the podcast inside to
uh it's way easier for me like it took
me a whole day to make one video and it
sucked now on I sit down on a Wednesday
Wednesday afternoon and I'll pump out 14
videos but that's after pot i hope i
have almost two thousand videos
something like that on the channel it's
crazy so i can do it a lot faster now
but it took me a long time at the start
i said an entire day to do one video but
it's like anything else you learn to
ride a bike it takes you a long time to
get up and then boom you're up yeah
every time you get up it's a lot faster
all easier but do you have similar
experiences with your broadcast the
podcast is a lot of work so you spend
time doing the interview you might slap
your words because you're worried about
the technology and also
person is speaking to and the questions
are going to ask and then once you've
completed you take it home or what have
you then you edit it and then you splice
it and then you render it so there's a
lot more work with the videos it's just
a conversation and it flows naturally
and it's there there's there's not that
much work to do with it there may be a
bit of editing afterwards but no on the
whole it seems a whole lot easier but no
notice my stray hairs now so I've got to
go and get my haircut yeah there you go
you gotta look better when you're on
video um another question swc most
creatives I know dabble and switch from
one thing to another how long you
recommend that a person sticks with one
thing before doing something else I'm a
big believer in following your flow fun
what you're excited about tell them what
you're passionate bub and as
entrepreneurs we often have entrepreneur
avd in like starting something and then
we got tired of it move to something
else and I think that's actually okay i
think if you try to force yourself to
stick with something that you're not
enjoying your being pulled somewhere
else you're not going to get you're
never going to get great results doing
something that you're not passionate
about I think just with some things
you'll find you'll have more sustained
excitement in there are some projects
that I start and launch and I'll usually
get it to the point where either this is
making money this makes sense it
continued on and I'm going to give it
off to my team to manage or it's not I'm
not going to kill it and so many
projects I've killed um and there's been
things that I've picked up you know like
rock climb when I went and tried and I
hated it like things in my crotch and
it's too tired that's like the heights
and I just didn't enjoy it would be my
first choice in school but I'm willing
to try like that's part of his exploring
and trying see um some things I picked
up and I'd like for a little bit and
then I dropped it because I lost the
passion and some things like
entrepreneurship it's been it's been I
don't know it's been over a decade for
sure and I still get energy from talking
entrepreneurs I love making YouTube
videos because because I love making
YouTube videos so I keep doing it if I
ever stop loving making YouTube videos
then I'll stop if I stop blowing
entrepreneurs then I'll stop and
hopefully it doesn't happen um
one or something that does drive my
excitement I don't you find the same
thing Dolores and what you're doing yeah
because there's things you do be out of
duty there's things you do because you
feel you should do it but when it's
something that you really want to do and
you loved doing it you get that
butterflying your tummy you get that
that feeling in a pity or tummy and do
you think yeah I love this I love doing
this this is me mm-hmm exactly cool yeah
there's another question from de meat
dimitra's hello Evan and Dolores greens
from the UK there you go I want to put
your hard times when nothing seemed to
work out for you and how that change
what did you do I think we covered that
at the beginning yeah when we went
pretty in in detail there Demetrius if
you watch the replay watch that will go
we want pretty in depth and then one
more question is swc asking about tips
as entrepreneurship tips for
entrepreneurship for for young people
instead of seeking out a job and I mean
I covered that a little bit already and
how I turned down job offers to go and
start my own business um but I don't
think a job is a bad thing because it's
a learning ground isn't it as long as
you think if you know that's not it's
not going to define you that's not where
you're going to stay is somewhere to
learn yeah I mean I think the reason to
take a job is to learn don't take a job
with money take a job to learn and
ideally I would try to find a job at a
smaller business if you know that your
your vision you want to be an
entrepreneur you want to start a company
in the graphic design industry as an
example go find a graphic design company
that has 10 employees you know it's a
small enough shop they're not just
starting out but they're you know
they've grown but they're not too big
and and try to work with them and get as
close to the entrepreneur found
responsible take on as many
responsibilities and projects as you can
you're getting paid to make mistakes
you're getting paid to learn it's like
going to entrepreneur university and not
risking your capital and instead you're
getting paid to do it so I think getting
a job can be a great way to spring
spring forward your your entrepreneurial
missions
make sure you're doing it to learn
something and find the targeted company
that you really want to learn from
absolutely yeah and then with the
questions man keep coming in Darren
Darren Shan what do Evan and dolores
think I'm suffering from an emotional
disorder after i put my medicine because
of financial problems i'm putting myself
it's hard for myself to get the goal and
be successful hmm baby we learn speak
with someone speak to someone that you
trust I big believer in talking
therapies um when you when it's all this
information is in your head um and it's
going around around around you need a
bit us that maybe get it down on paper
and then you can make some claret get
some clarity out of it once it's on
paper and then find someone you trust to
talk it through it because maybe once
you talk it through things may not seem
as bad as you feel it is when it's in
your head everything is magnified yeah
I'm always hesitant to give personally
any kind of medical advice but what I do
find is with it when you have a goal a
lot of people don't have important
enough goals a lot of people don't have
a big enough why and you'll find that
when you have a really important goal
you'll you'll go through almost anything
to go and accomplish it right you'll
give up sleep you'll push off meetings
you'll you'll push away other things to
spend time to focus on that goal so I
think like having having a big goal
something that motivates you something
that you you can't wait to get up and be
excited and go work towards is really
important and it's not just about making
money I think that's a lot of a mistake
a lot of entrepreneurs make if your goal
is just to make money you're never going
to make money if you look at the most
successful entrepreneurs when they
started their business they were deeply
passionate about something they added a
ton of value to the industry and they
made money as a result of following
their passion and adding value and
helping people are the people who just
try to make money you're gonna quit
because it's too hard as soon as
something as hard so this is a roadblock
you're going to quit and go do something
else because you're never that
to sit in the first place yeah and I
believe there's a shift happening
because in the 80s I think it was all
geared towards bankers and making money
and that wasn't sustainable and I think
there is a shift now where you see the
ones who are becoming successful whether
or not they realize it they're giving
people what they want they're helping
more people to get what they want and so
that in turn is making them successful
so it is about sharing giving and taking
even if they don't realize it in here
yeah so we've got a couple minutes left
maybe we can shift from the from the
questions back to dolores and i don't
know if there's anything else you wanted
to cover and talk get some of the
questions really really important one
even ok really Morton now you got to be
think hard about this one Oh what's your
preference Cuban or New York style ah
I'm a la style [ __ ] salsa here ah
yeah yeah la la style which is le New
York but it's on one instead of on on to
you see you could you confuse me already
because I I love Cuban Cuban and because
of that circular thing it's just in my
head and I can't get used to adjust to
anything else really ok next big
question so my final question when you
started this whole venture and this is
something that I also armed people my
podcast entities is there something that
you wish someone had told you before you
started someone who was wise and done it
before what piece of information do you
wish they're giving it um that's a great
question I'm putting my best that's a
much harder question in the last one um
I think honestly it would be to believe
in myself more uh because I almost quit
right like I quit I did quit and that
could have been the end and I don't you
know I don't know what really made me
get up that next day
and want to go back but I almost quit my
business and and I didn't have anybody
to say that this is normal like who
talks about wanting to quit being normal
right here you talk to entrepreneurs and
it's always oh yeah I meet this big sale
and things are going really well where
everybody thinks about quitting at some
point it's like this dirty secret of
entrepreneurship that we're not willing
to share and I had no idea I felt like
everybody's doing so well I look at all
these companies taking off and Here I am
sucking why wasn't happening and I feel
like a total failure um and I think if
somebody if somebody came and told me
that I would have felt a lot better yeah
normal yeah and and and hopefully maybe
would have started even earlier right
like I guess I wish I had more influence
is early on in my life to show me the
road of entrepreneurship because I'm
very fortunate that I discovered this
and I I almost didn't and man I would
not be happy knowing me now you know
working at some bank or doing some job
for somebody else so um yeah I'm it was
just by like a sliver that I made it
through and I think with the right
guidance and exposure I could have
increased that percentage mm-hmm how do
you have you set yourself a deadline
when you have to reach your your billion
entrepreneur I I don't and I don't even
have really like a solid roadmap cuz I
don't think you'd know even because
there's so many people who wouldn't
necessarily interact they just watch the
videos get the newsletter or yeah so you
wouldn't necessarily know when you
preach them I've already done it yeah
yeah the way that I'm officially
tracking is the views on my website to
have how to billing people come to the
website and check it out but you're
right there's a lot more ways than I'm
reaching people through YouTube and
through my speaking and the book that's
coming out and all that stuff I think
what it helps me do is now frame
everything in a much bigger way so I
only take on projects where
it has the ability to reach millions of
people if what I'm doing you introduced
into an opportunity if that opportunity
doesn't allow me to reach millions of
people potentially then I'm not
interested in doing it and so having
that bigger vision bigger goal helps me
continue to think big myself and not be
bogged down on my time but things that
are a lot smaller brilliant Evan thank
you Anna there you go before I talk your
ears off so thank you thank you so much
and i'm going to replay this one today
and put it on the put it on wherever
anyone listen okay so thank you and
thank you for inspiration going to wake
up to you in the morning okay Thank You
Dolores and thank you to everybody who's
watching and commenting as well as been
a lot of fun